[Music]
my name is Forest Brazil and it's so
great to welcome you here to the
developer keynote at Google Cloud next
along with my good friend and co-host
Richard CER hi Richard that was absurd
but that was awesome who who doesn't
want more of that did that just for you
Richard Hey listen it's great to see you
out here in Legacy land what are you
doing here yeah you know every time I
have built anything successful which is
rare it has still found a way to become
Legacy that's right well honestly you
know Legacy it's just a fancy word for
the thing that works right the thing
that generates Revenue that's right so
let's get a show of hands who here has
been running something that's been in
prod for five years five years 10 yeah
do I get 10 15 do I get 15 15 20 what
what are you doing 20 years that is
amazing uh we'll give some T-shirts
there's a lot of value over the years
that's awesome right but there's also
some pain it's not all
celebration yeah we get there's some
pain there too right yeah you know
Google itself is actually turning 25
years old this year so we've been
through our share of growing pains as
well for example back in 2008 Google was
running into a persistent bug on our
load balancers which back then they were
thirdparty Hardware devices now these
devices they couldn't do layer three in
cap they couldn't push large configs and
when the network experienced a type of
traffic called ARP storms the load
balancers would enter a catastrophic
failure mode and the vendor said fixing
the problems wasn't a high enough
priority for
now our traffic site reliability
engineering team said fix it or we'll
figure out another solution and the
vendor said good luck so the sres
decided to roll their own load balancing
in software on top of commodity Linux
servers and that's how we developed
maglev which is the faster more reliable
technology that's been balancing all our
data center traffic since 2009 that
includes all our Cloud Lo balancers
right yeah the whole cloudload balancing
family too but here's my favorite part
of the story okay Trisha Weir who was
one of the brilliant sres who helped to
launch maglev she had one of those
Legacy load balancer devices bronzed and
here's a picture that she sent of it
check out that engraving on the top in
loving memory one feature too few one
ARP storm too many talk about
celebrating your legacy that's right I
think the real moral of the story is you
do not mess with our traffic sres so
I'll go one better though let's one up
you so back around 2010 or so riters
discovered an unintentional feature of
Google translate anybody remember this
oh that UI that's a in the past yeah so
if you went into this old translate UI
and took this particular sense of
nonsense syllables then translated from
English to German came out sounding like
this man seems pretty Harless I love
that little that's my favorite one yeah
it's pretty pretty harmless I would say
so I mean there was one problem with
this service though it wasn't
provisioned to be super large so would
that beatboxing feature you know would
mess things up if it ever went viral so
of course it went viral every time slash
do or readd it thought it'd be hilarious
they they'd nail the service and the
service would fall over and our poon
call folks would get paged so the
short-term fix was something we all do
we over-provision the service now of
course you could cash and do things like
that but the root problem was that
generating sounds expensive so we had to
reduce that disparity between the ease
of a single user making a request and
then the CPU cost of generating audio
and that's one of the drivers that led
us to the architecture Innovations we
enjoy today like on device ml
translation and voice synthesis that's
right you know I love that story Richard
because it reminds us that dealing with
these surprising edge cases right in
Legacy workloads it's a big part of how
we innovate and take the next step past
that Legacy yeah so look so far you've
heard a bunch of exciting announcements
here at next you might be asking all
right how do these help me out in Legacy
land where maybe I don't get to choose a
brand new tech stack tomorrow and I have
a limited number of innovation tokens I
get to spend and business constraints on
when and where I can spend them so today
we're going to share some lore if you
will about how Google Engineers have
rebuilt our own legacy over the years
and we're going to show you how some of
the latest Google Cloud features you
might have heard about so far at next
can help you do that too but we're going
to need some help so we invited some
very special people to help us out some
of our Google Cloud Champion innovators
that's right yeah the champion
innovators come from all over the world
they are some of the top experts in
Google cloud and uh they're solving real
problems every day with Google Cloud so
they're going to help help us figure out
how to get the most out of all these
brand new features in fact we have a
pretty strong contingent of Champions in
the room with us today where you at
Champions there's our Champions here we
go awesome great to have you here that's
an enthusiastic Bunch all right well hey
let's meet some of our Champions now
confirmance
recording there he is and if you could
remove your glasses with the glasses off
get you a little bit
centered perfect
[Music]
when we're talking about Legacy
Legacy all
first it gives me this uneasy
feeling I would say it's a robust cic
pipeline best possible hybrid solution
for us it's putting generative AI to
work but then the key thing to me is
always the the talent right
security oh sorry cut you off too
early crash production server on a
Friday night technical level of people
coming into the
platforms a perfect world in a perfect
world perfect world training learning
taking ideas and sharing it out to the
community
you know infrastructure and you know
modernization is is all of it together
to me in a perfect world all the
technicians can make the Investments
they need to to help our systems work
right that's fantastic that's all we
[Music]
need thanks so much
Champions yeah that's
right well over the next few minutes
four of these amazing Champion
innovators are going to help Richard and
me take you on a whirlwind tour of four
big areas where new features from Google
Cloud can help us build our next Legacy
application development platform
engineering security and data
development with AI and uh if that
graphic looks kind of like a roller
coaster to you well maybe that's apt
because all the demos you're going to
see today are 100% live let's hope this
works but first up to help us reimagine
what building apps looks like in a
generative AI world we have Champion
innovator and workspace GTE Alice keer
Alice come on
[Music]
up hey Al hey thanks so much for being
here thank you Alice you are known as
the queen of spreadsheets is that right
that is right I always say that in
another life I would have been a
spreadsheet but in this life I'm a
Google Cloud innovator champion and I'm
a big fan of using Google workspace to
automate whatever I can as quickly as
possible with spreadsheets right the
answer is always a spreadsheet automate
everything and if necessary use code oh
I like that that should be on a t-shirt
so Alice of the new announcements at
next which are you most excited about so
far well I think a lot of us are getting
this question from our stakeholders
right now what is the highest leverage
use of our time and generative a has AI
has changed that calculus a little bit
hasn't it see you're a math teacher I
see what you did there yeah that's right
so I'm interested in Duet AI but
particularly duet
in app sheet like how can I automate
with just those tools that's right so
recall that duet AI which who's heard
the term duet AI at time or two at next
so far a few of us have it's our new
generative AI capability it's integrated
into the core of both Google workspace
and Google Cloud right and it can help
you write code analyze security threats
and even develop applications or so
we've been told so let's do this let's
take kind of a gnarly use case and let's
see how far we can get into it using
just duet Ai and app sheet before we
have to parachute out into some kind of
custom code sound good yeah deal awesome
so what should we build gosh in my day
job I'm a teacher helping people get the
most out of Google workspace and I hear
a lot of surprising use cases to start
with a spreadsheet yeah so how about uh
incident reporting so let's say for
example that I'm a school resource
officer right or maybe even the shift
supervisor on a factory floor I might
want a consistent way for anybody to
report safety incidents or maybe just
near misses yeah like maybe just taking
a picture with their phones yeah okay so
uh let's build a prototype now I'm going
to pop into Google Chat where I have the
app sheet bot which in fact is powered
by duet AI now what do we want the
features of this thing to be gosh I mean
I wanted to easily capture data using a
phone or tablet so anyone in the school
or on the shop floor can initiate a
report the safety team should have an
operational dashboard so they can track
and escalate issues and we're going to
want some help from it to establish a
method for it AI to evaluate the
pictures for specific areas to see if
they are in compliance sounds good so
let me see if I can get that into a
prompt that du I can use so I need to
capture incident reports each incident
has a type status description a date and
each incident should be assigned to what
a team member right so let's put this in
and see what happens now I didn't
exactly give duet AI an architecture
diagram there so it's going to be
interesting to see how it things an app
like this should be built and look at
this what it gave us is a couple of
tables so we've got a team members table
and we've got an incident table and as
we can see by this team member ID it
seems to think there should be some
relationship between them so that seems
cool we can click on this little pencil
if we want to make changes to this but
actually I think we can also do that
through chat so any changes you think we
should make oh you know it looks pretty
good so far but you know can we provide
some constraints on the type of incident
because I really just think that should
not be a free text field I think you're
right so we'll say type should be major
or minor and then let see if duet can
actually apply this to our app
description and it looks like that it's
actually changed it to a list Isn't that
cool it can strain that field for us so
it'll want us to look at our app
structure again just confirm that uh it
still looks like what we want and it
looks about the same so now we'll just
Advance through the next couple of uh
prompts here we can add notifications if
we want did you know that you can get
lots and lots of email from M if you
like I love email I know you do well
just to be kind to your inbox we'll skip
that for right now and then all we have
to do is Click create app and uh when I
click on this the theoretically we're
going to get a whole web application
could I get some game show music please
let's see what happens all right hold
tight let's see what happens so it's
going to set up our new app I feel very
excited about this you don't believe it
I don't think it's going to happen all
right so it's going to customize our
features our design I don't know exactly
what's going on behind the scenes there
but here we go we've actually got an app
yay what and so this is actually let me
just Orient you to what's going on here
we've built an application that can be
responsive to a mobile uh tablet or
desktop versions and you can see that
it's created a couple of views for us
one is our list of incidents and then
the other is our list of uh team members
that might be assigned to those
incidents and uh if you check this out
we can tweak anything we want in the app
sheet IDE uh if we need to so we've got
data here and you can see it's created
two tables for me um it's got listed all
of our fields that we need we can change
those types but Alice I know you're
going to love this if I click on view
data source here okay all right and we
look at what's actually looking behind
this what does that look like to you oh
my gosh it kind of looks like a Google
sheet spreadsheet it does yes but
actually under the hood this is a full
relational database it's running on
spanner uh and as you can see duet was
kind enough to provision some example
data for us which is nice to see but I
actually don't need it so I'm going to
clear that out for
now well for can we add an integration
back into Google Chat as well so the
safety team can be notified and take
action when an incident is reported a
preent question yes you can so there is
a chat app integration right here in app
sheet and I can click through that and
actually provision that with just a
couple of clicks that might take a
second it's provisioning a new Google
Cloud project in the background so we'll
give that a second to run now another
cool thing I want to call out is that
there's actually an app sheet phone app
so we've built a mobile app here as well
as a desktop app so do this for me go
ahead and tap the app sheet app on your
phone you see that there yeah it says
incident tracker oh look at this wow
it's already up there for us yeah and so
we've got our incident list it's empty
cuz I just deleted all that sample data
so that was what I'm not going to say it
was 2 minutes not everything takes 2
minutes okay but uh it wasn't that many
minutes we just shipped a web and mobile
app and we mostly use natural language
right to describe it so as a developer
this is really getting my wheels turning
right like how much farther can I go
before I have to start writing code yeah
good question like ideally I shouldn't
even have to type the incident report
right like I'm imagine trying to do this
with a walkie-talkie in one hand while I
have a stack of papers to grade so can I
just narrate it with my voice that is a
great use for another cool thing we just
shipped which is unstructured audio
capture with du AI so try this I want
you to hit that plus button there all
right and then hit the audio button and
we're going to see if we can just
narrate this new incident report so you
don't have to go a and hit the audio
button for me you don't have to like
narrate exactly what's in each field
which is good because you can't actually
see them right now just kind of tell
duet more or less what you think should
be in this report and we'll see if it
can connect the dots so go ahead right
so I'm thinking this is a minor security
incident that happened
yesterday oh analyze
see what
happens oh it's minor incident minor in
the date is what is today the 30th yeah
yesterday at 12: a.m. okay so we could
tweak that by hand if we needed but it
works so we'll hit accept values yeah
and then hit save and then I should see
that pop right back up here in the
desktop version as well because this is
all pretty well synced yep and I've got
one incident there oh and I should even
call out you don't have to have this
boring uh list view if you want we've
got table views and gallery views and
all kinds of different things that can
show up here super super cool so we've
been back to app sheet and we've seen uh
that we've actually able to autoc
classify that response into our form so
we went from idea to app in some number
of seconds we added these rich user
experiences with audio capture and chat
but there's one more big feature Alice
that you said you wanted to add there is
and that's the ability to actually take
a picture of our workstation here and
see if the AI can figure out if it's in
or out of compliance yeah wa can we do
it with app sheet ah well uh no uh we're
going to have to break the glass and
connect this
good Lord connect this app to vertex AI
oh well it was fun while it lasted for
us it was fun but this is where reality
kicks in right I mean as a developer
with existing workloads you're likely
going to have existing apis and LL
models and and so on that you want to
make available to other parts of the
business and it turns out that app sheet
lets you put a new front end on that
stuff super quickly while staying in the
Google workspace world of single sign on
with familiar forms and such exactly so
let's say that I've built anazing vertex
AI Vision model to help identify
pictures of workstations that are out of
compliance actually let's not say that
let's show it I actually have that app
available right now it's built out in a
different Google Cloud project um it's
behind an apogee API and it looks a
little something like this okay cool so
you can see some amazing uh developer
styling going on in that diagram but uh
what we're looking at here is it's a a
cloud run service that uh fronts vertex
AI it's going to run a few little uh
prompts for us and then it's going to
come back asynchronously and call back
to app sheet so theoretically we should
be able to add that into our app sheet
project not there but if I go back to my
data we should be able to add it if I
click plus there and we're going to hit
ape API and we've got this little
inspections API so if I click on that
and hit add this table it should come
through uh and this is my favorite thing
check this out you all it actually reads
like if I go to this new inspections
table it actually reads for me the open
API spec and it pulls in all these
fields for the new table so it's got you
know whether it looks safe for Tex is
going to determine that the image that
we want to upload all that good stuff
Isn't that cool it is so cool but I just
want to clarify you can trigger any API
here in that EP sheet is able to call
via web hook now I'm an appscript fan
girl and I do love that you can invoke
calls to appscript in app sheet as well
as cloudsql and cloud storage and I love
that you said appscript and app sheet
two times in three words perfectly
that's incredible uh all right so what
we're going to do here is wire this up
as a new view in our app uh Google chat
with du AI actually did this for us
automatically before but if I go back to
my views and I hit plus here look here's
duet again it's actually going to let us
uh create a new view and uh before I do
that I have to resolve a schema issue so
let me go back to my incidence table
let's see what's going on here oh it
requires an image field for the
incidence view so check this out all
right so we've got a uh sometimes things
don't always work exactly the way we
wanted but that's okay because I have a
separate app on the side what's a legacy
rule redundancy right so check this out
I've got another application up here
that I can use so in my inspections list
I can actually wire up a view and it
looks like this you can see I've got
this inspections list right here and
it's got a sample uh workspace here with
fire extinguishers and good things like
that so now we should be able to submit
our own pictures back to vertex to
evaluate them for safety so if you go
back uh to your app view here we're
going to go back to our app that's good
and perfect and working a cool corporate
app all right and then go and hit that
plus button let's see if we capture a
picture and I see that we're going to
take a picture so can we snap a selfie
of us let's take a selfie the whole room
does that work oh that works awesome all
right so take a
photo here we go everyone say app sheet
AB
sheet awesome all right okay save let's
hit yep let's hit save all right and now
if you pop open this card here okay it's
going to take a second for vertex AI to
read this picture and I want us all to
just take a moment and enjoy this live
demo moment that we're in together isn't
this wonderful it's the best just sit
with this for a minute don't feel
uncomfortable feel comfortable here this
is a great place to be isn't it Alice
and look we got this a man and a woman
are posing for a picture in front of a
screen that says broadcasting on it
that's not too bad it's not too bad
awesome and it says it looks safe so
we're in compliance amazing we are safe
I love this because everything from the
cloud function backwards can be owned by
me the developer and my team but this
gives me the option to let some of of
those business teams put together their
own dashboards and reports and so on and
lets me focus on where I can provide
unique value that's exactly right so in
just a few minutes what did we do we
shipped a web and mobile application
prototype using natural language prompts
we built an audio capture with duet aai
and we called out to other apis and
machine learning services on Google
Cloud all that is table Stakes now right
so that just means we get to think even
bigger always Alice Keeler thank you so
much for being so much for us this was
fun thanks everybody appreciate you
my name is Anna be berenberg and I've
been engineer at Google since 2006 and
now I'm engineering fellow in Google
Cloud when I mov in cloud in 2015 to
work on networking products I noticed
that some of our engineering teams were
having trouble with development velocity
so I ask a question how long does it
take to make a small change a shipping a
single bullet true or false for our
Global load balancer think about your
own products and and ask yourself that
question how many Engineers does it take
to Plum a bull through your stock while
you're thinking about that let me show
what our architecture look like this is
a real microservice graph of the path
the bull had to travel from the time
customer had to configure it to the time
it took effect on load balancer this
involved eight teams an API design a
management Control Data plane teams ux
UI Tech writers and more all these teams
were located in six offices reporting to
three VPS to sh r that bull I had to
convince all eight teams to make the
feature priority just thinking about
that makes me tired but even I succeeded
at that with the dependencies between
the team individual priorities and
competition for resources it would take
6 months to deliver the feature for one
Boolean they had to speed this up how do
you build a platform where T product
teams can develop fast the short answer
is a combination of vertical and
horizontal ownership we had to empower
each vertical team to deliver a feature
without this endless matrix of
dependencies and we had to build
extensible but still shared horizontal
infrastructure that everybody could use
first we emphasize pluggability in our
horizontal infrastructure second we've
advocated the use of Open Source tools
and apis wherever possible for
portability and third we doubled down on
what I reuse of these extensible layers
I call it one of everything eff heard
one network one workload identity one
artifact register over the next few
years these principles inform the
elements of our our modern management
control and data ples and while we still
have lots of work to do over time we
move faster and faster for example our
traffic director team built on this new
infrastructure to cut their time of
shipping a new API from months to a few
weeks de deployed in all regions in
production I believe that as a
developers we need to think how
platforms and product architecture
enables development and release velocity
whether it's through pluggability
portability or reuse of shared services
our goal is to deliver the best
functionality as quickly as possible one
bullet a Time thank
you that sounds familiar doesn't doesn't
it that's a pretty common thing that
happens
so thank you Anna she makes us think in
platforms every day which is a is a
privilege so look so far we've seen how
far duet Ai and app sheet can get you
when you want to add new workflows to
existing systems but let's be real a lot
of the things you might be working on
still involve a lot more traditional
Cloud building blocks you're slinging
containers you're tweaking release
pipelines and we want to build those
platforms as efficiently and reliably as
possible so to help us learn how to do
that please welcome Google Cloud
Champion innovator Lucas
Carlson
[Applause]
[Music]
hello hello hello great to have you here
stoked to be here yeah I can tell you're
pumped uh Lucas what is your kind of
biggest Focus right now is you're
thinking about managing infrastructure
for cloud workloads well you know I
would say the three main things that I'm
always trying to improve first how our
applications respond to scaling events
how do we better handle surges in
traffic sure second we want to make sure
the INF structure is easy to maintain
for our platform engineering teams so
they can spend more time doing things
that add value rather than just keeping
the lights on and finally we always want
to make sure that we can build
experiences that are more personalized
for our customers nice well I happen to
have an existing workload here I want
your thoughts on it is a dynamic python
app deployed to Cloud run so for anyone
to follow along not right now you're
focused on me but later uh I got this
from one of Google Cloud's jump start
solutions so these are guided
deployments for a bunch of of different
application scenarios you can check them
out anytime it's an amazing way to to
try the cloud so let's take a look what
I'm going to be showing you here is one
of the jumpstart Solutions this is a
dynamic web application I just deployed
you can see we show you the reference
architecture there's tutorials built in
and you can see it's pretty
straightforward right I've got some
containers in Cloud run I'm using
postgress I'm even using Cloud build for
CI and CD here and I see you got
Firebase for your CDN so sweet nothing
gets past you yeah that's that's right
so look this is a great app for retail
store but let's say it was a V1 we've
learned some stuff right that's been
running in production a while we've seen
some issues we want to improve so first
we want to revisit some of the
assumptions on scale functionality and
even deployment strategy so we've
learned we've got some spiky usage in
need to scale so what's my plan there
well you know there's been a lot of new
features released recently in Cloud R
especially and so maybe some of those
might be useful here I like your
thinking let's start off with how we
might handle surges in traffic here in
Cloud Run Okay so the first thing you
want to do is check your minimum and
maximum instances all right let's see
what we got so let's see yeah look I'm
being cheap so it looks like you got
your minimum instances set to zero so
let's bump that one up to one it's fair
great with your minimum insist set to
one you'll always have at least one
container running ready to serve traffic
now we should probably keep an eye on
utilization so let's check on those Max
instances they might need to be raised
as well all right I'm not made of money
so we just got to okay that limit there
so setting that minimum instances bit
solves that 0o to one problem but as
those instances scale up I still have a
cold start right indeed so there's
actually another really cool feature
that came out a preview recently that
you might want to experiment with it's
called CPU
boost all right CPU boost allocates more
CPU at startup time specifically to
reduce your cold starts so this can
actually cut startup time in half for
some workloads but it's actually
language and package dependent so you
might want to test it out for yourself
all right yeah it's just a single check
box I feel so productive so look the
initial experiment proved that people
like the app we fix some of the scaling
but now we want to push it to more
places from just one region to maybe
multiple this is where Cloud deploy can
come in it's one of my favorite Services
mine too actually so Cloud deploy is
fully managed so it works with gke and
Cloud run and it's actually also seen a
ton of upgrades since being uh shipped
last year right for our app we want to
make sure that we can move the app from
Dev to test to prod okay perfect so
Cloud deploy also recently added the
ability to deploy to multiple Targets in
the single stage so for example imagine
deploying to three different regions at
the same time that's super useful that's
super dice yeah I love that so I can
trigger this Pipeline with a single CLI
command I can even do it in the UI now
they just added that in real life you'd
probably run this as the final step in
your CI process exactly all right so
let's jump to the console and see this
in real life just deoy this backstage
here we go okay so what I really like
about this improved ux in the cloud
console here is you can see all the
things you need to see for example you
have your running pipeline here you have
all the dorom metrics and then you can
see all the information about each
release yep and even promotion between
environments is easy Canary deployments
it's awesome so if you try one service
after next try Cloud deploy so look we
fixed the scaling needs of our app but
what about some functional improvements
we got the easy stuff but now let's
actually kind of fix some of the app we
notice that it's a retail app right so
we have some abandoned carts a little
more than usual and we want to poke
those customers good idea I don't know
let's see if duet Ai and Cloud
workstations can uh help us write some
code excellent you can't say no to me
all right so if we look at the
application there we go okay so I'm a
big fan of duet AI doing autoc
completion of code but also it can
generate entire blocks of code here for
example you have a comment just from
that we can generate all all the code we
need to talk to postgress database to
Loop through the rows and then to email
each customer that has an abandoned card
that's right I like your confidence
though let's see there we go yeah so
generate a ton of code for me and gr
look my parents raised me right so I'm
also going to add some test coverage to
this and so right from the IDE I can
pick the operation or even do it right
from chat but I can pick the operation
and say generate unit tests it'll jump
over to the do i chat right where we can
ask questions but it'll also throw me
some unit test which I can copy back
into my code run them and make good
choices here I love this feature so much
I'm actually talking about this a little
later so feel free to come by to that
nice um so in reality you wouldn't want
this background task that's going to be
emailing people about Abandoned cards to
be like built into your web app you
probably want to run it as like a
scheduled job or a Cron job in
kubernetes or something like that now
for me actually the way I prefer to do
this these days is using Cloud run jobs
which is a new run to completion
capability for background work it has
all the infrastructure complexity just
like everything else in Cloud run
serverless love it serverless so let's
deploy this new email reminder service
to a cloud run via the job we can jump
back into the
console and you can see look it's really
easy to build new jobs if you like Cloud
run it's the same sort of simple process
pick a container pick how often it runs
and you're good to go I can use the UI
the CI even terraform to deploy this
terraform so once I have the job running
we can see that this email sender is set
up to run on a schedule on a regular
basis and when it's not running cost me
nothing serverless serverless awesome so
let's take a step back think about what
we just did here in just a few minutes
we made our application more performant
with CPU
boost and instance configuration we use
parallel deploys to actually serve this
in more regions to different users and
then we're running running fully managed
Cloud run jobs without writing a whole
ton of code that we have have to
maintain perfect yeah I would recommend
that if you're using Cloud run you might
want to take a few minutes and check out
some of the recent feature announcements
and see what capabilities are available
to you that team moves pretty quickly so
you may be surprised at what you find
that's right well let's hear for Lucas
that was awesome thanks bud thank you so
[Applause]
much and now it's time for another
Legacy
[Music]
law
December 9th 2021 was a dark and stormy
night okay it wasn't stormy we're in
California we don't do that whole
weather thing I was living in a house
with two other senior Engineers who work
on Google's technical Incident
Management team and we knew something
like messy was going down when
everyone's pager woke us up at 3 in the
morning turns out there was a zerod day
vulnerability in a little open-source
Java Library called log for
J my name is Adrien waler I've been a
technical program manager in Sr at
Google for more more than 10 years and I
work in Incident Management all right CU
music that makes me sound cool log for J
is a popular logging framework for Java
applications and this zero day announced
a well publicized way that unauthorized
users could execute code on your
computer as
you that's scary for one computer
multiply that into the billions to
represent all the Production Services
all the internal applications all the
build
tooling any customer compromise romise
is
unacceptable and this zero day
announcement kind of kicked off a rased
against the clock to patch everything
before any malicious actor can try
anything our security lead immediately
said security folks we need a patch and
we want full forensics on any potential
exploits technical incident Response
Team tell affected folks what's
happening and roll out the patch
easy
right well this is where Google's Legacy
is kind of a double-edged sword Google
search was released in 1998 and ever
since our product lineup has been
expanding through Innovation and
Acquisitions like Android YouTube looker
as folks from mandiant you heard from
yesterday this means that our systems do
not have consistent back ends so how do
you determine who's calling the log forj
Library who who's even responsible for
managing that we weren't just looking
for a needle in a Hast stack we were
looking for a th000 needles in a million
hay stacks we don't know where the hay
stacks are located and some of them
might not even
beave so how can we make this
happen super fast at Google
scale clear communication and
coordination were key so my team went
back to the basics breaking the problems
down into smaller manageable chunks with
old school classics like spreadsheets
documentation and
flowcharts I love flowcharts so much
here is the original chart that I drew
to help our teams follow the right
process for patching log
forj doesn't have ion steps it just
communicates as directly and simply as
possible what every team needs to do now
we never found any instance of a
successful exploit of log forj at
Google but a
week of round the-clock security updates
left us feeling rough Incident
Management is it's a human expensive
activity and it really takes a toll on
the people in
involved that week my household went
through like 2 lbs of coffee beans and
zero
showers not cute but if you were on
Google Cloud that week you had one last
thing to worry about we were a
well-organized force of caffeinated
brain power so you didn't have to be now
moving beyond our Back to Basics
approach we've since established a
specialized Cloud technical Incident
Management function to provide clear
communication and coordinated responses
to Future incidents delivering that kind
of cloud customer experience that our
partners deserve may your ped stay
silent thank you very
much
wow thank you Adrien well who here
remembers where they were the night that
the log for vulnerability dropped yeah
it was a sleepless night for a lot of us
but thankfully less than it could have
been Thanks to Adrienne and her team
okay well hey it's great to be back with
you let me without further Ado introduce
you to our next Champion innovator Mark
Johnson Mark come on up
[Music]
[Applause]
here Mark it's so great to have you here
thank you for being here amazing I've
got to ask you a question though you
have 14 Google Cloud certifications why
would someone do that to themselves well
for us it's great to be here and let's
say about those CTS I love learning but
I love paying ah yeah well apparently
given that you also work on cloud
migrations in your day job is that right
absolutely all the time and you know
working with big Enterprises it's a lot
of fun but change is always constant
always a constant and listen we've
explored how some of the latest Google
Cloud features so far can help us build
apps in new ways right and how they can
help us run them uh faster and easier
but in the real world in the Legacy
world we have even more things to think
about don't we so you know we got to
talk about security got to talk about
security so take for example that little
Cloud runback app that Richard and Lucas
were looking at a moment ago what do we
need to do to make an app like this and
its deployment process safe for
production so the first thing I would
ask is those Cloud run services that you
were deploying how are we going to vet
what's packaged into those container
images and what's our software supply
chain security story ah yes the dreaded
s3c so I like to think about s3c in
three pieces number one how are we
securing our developer environment
number number two how are we ensuring
the Integrity of the build process
itself and then finally how do we
protect that app once it's running in
production so let's begin where all good
things begin in Cloud workstations I've
got a little python app here uh it's
pretty small so that it will build fast
but it's still going to take a minute to
build so I'm going to push it and while
it's building we'll dig into the s3c
enhanced pipeline that you can see I've
built here in my cloud build diagel and
then yet people like Cloud workstations
for the convenience factor but I
definitely think it's underrated
security tool you don't need to stop at
hopefully people are doing the right
thing we can actually create a policy
that enforces leas privileged access
that's exactly right so let me just kick
off the build of this app here and it's
running and uh while that's running
let's take a look at a previous run
actually that succeeded so I've got
Cloud buildup here and you can see I've
got a couple successful runs and when we
take a look at this notice we've got a
bunch of steps let me pull this out so
you can see it a little bit better that
are leading us down to something called
binary authorization and binary
authorization is basically a policy we
can set at the org level that says yes
this container image has past our
security checks and you're allowed to
deploy it that's exactly right so if I
jump over to Binary authorization here
in the console you'll see that not only
do I have the policy itself but next to
it I have something called a testers you
say what are ATT testers let me scroll
out so you can see those a little better
a testers I like to think of those kind
of like cryptographic Pokemon all right
and I'm going to collect those along the
way in order to earn that binary off
check mark at the end of my build
process so the first one you see here is
called assur OSS now assured OSS is a
repository of packages that Google
preets to help make sure that my python
packages aren't malicious how do I make
sure that I'm using Aur OSS well I get
to decide in this case in my cloud
build. yaml I'm calling a script called
assured OSS bin offz Dosh uh and that's
actually going to check these passes
packages it's just doing a compare and
uh if it finds some that aren't in
assured osss it's going to fail my build
otherwise it'll update the a tester and
we'll move on and this is why it's so
important to have a hosted Bill process
all those checks running on the cloud
buildt side so if you have people
pushing code these testers are not going
to get signed that's exactly right yeah
so I also see you having EST testation
uh to validate our container structure
as well y you can see that right here
and then I've got a third one that's
actually uh making sure that if I've got
any vulnerabilities in my containers
that I flag the build and I'm using
something called ctis to do that that's
an open source security policy enforcer
that uses the Google Cloud container
analysis API it's super cool
and for those of you out there trying to
be systematic about how you put together
a software supply chain security flow
like this I do recommend you check out
the salsa levels at salsa. deev they can
help you identify how mature your
security checks are and what you may be
missing that's right so if I go to Cloud
run where again I have the most recent
revision of this app running and I move
over to the security tab uh we can see
In This Cloud Run Security insights view
what all this looks like when the adest
stations pass and the binary
authorization succeeds I know it's a lot
of metadata on each step but you do have
your salsa build level for you here uh
you've got any fixes that you need to
look at and you've also got your
Providence so I'll zoom in so you can
see that a little better uh you not out
in how about that you can see you know
where this build came from where the
images were what time you last messed
with it all those things that can be
hard to find unless they're pulled into
one place which here they conveniently
are and it's also important to call out
here that all these insights are also
available in the new gke Enterprise now
via the fleet view that's right so if
you haven't seen yet cuz I know it's new
this is what the fleet view looks like
for gke Enterprise I've got a couple of
gke clusters running in this environment
and you can see I've got this kind of
top level view that shows me any uh
misconfigurations or vulnerabilities in
my environment I like that it has This
concerns tab I want a concerns tab for
my life that would be super cool have
all of those things stack ranked for me
but at least we have it in gke actually
let me show you one other thing that's
really cool we have this Advanced
vulnerabilities section down here and
these are not just container level
vulnerabilities it's actually going down
to the language package level so you see
these go vulnerabilities that it found
it's finding those and you're running
containers and I love how this isn't
just some point in time assessment that
happens when you publish something to
your container registry which you can
and should do by the way and artifact
registry can do it for you but you can
actually use this to assess risk for
containers that are currently running in
production and the best thing is there's
no cost to run either of this so I tell
all my clients who are using jke just
turn on security posture in that Fleet
view literally no downsides at all and
it can come up big for you someday
that's right so so let's get back to
that build uh I kind of feel like we
should break something make it real I I
agree with you I don't believe
something's working till I've seen it
fail so this is where I I come clean I
confess to you that before I push that
code just now um I secretly took one of
the cves out of the allow list in our
container analysis step and so without
that we should see that our build has
failed successfully and it has so that's
good to know uh for as you double cross
us you're playing games you know an
Insider attack you got to watch out for
those too so we should also call this
out in certain situations if you choose
to buy pass binary authorization
enforcement and deploy or serve a
container that violates the policy you
can click The Brak glass button along
with a justification that's right so you
can see here all this scary Red text
saying that the binary authorization
failed and I can click that break class
button this will be captured in the
cloud audit logs but of course the
permission to bypass that should be
provided very selectively if at all
don't make me get on or go on a tangent
about Le privilege access for us we got
to lock this down got to lock it down so
we've looked at how we safely get our
code to production right now we've got
to look at how we keep it safe once it's
get there once once it gets there so
let's go to another of my favorite
places in Google Cloud which is the
security Command Center and I want to
jump into the vulnerabilities View and
let's just see if we have anything that
jumps out at us about our current
environment setup so you'll see there's
going to be a bunch of things that pop
up here some of them I'm more or less
concerned about but it's this admin
service account that really jumps out to
me so I'm going to drill into that for
just a second and you'll notice a couple
of things here uh number one if I jump
into this what do we see something's
loading here for
us
hopefully hey Google make it go faster
there you go there you go awesome what
AI generated summary is actually
generated by duet AI that's right yeah
you may remember this from the main
keynote yesterday but it's going to give
us some verbiage about how we why it's
not good that we haven't added service
account with all these extra privileges
but watch this we can actually go deeper
than just a summary if I click on the
attack score itself these attack
exposure scores you'll see next to these
vulnerabilities now and that's just
based on WE rank these vulnerabilities
as high medium or low concern we have a
numeric score assigned to those you can
actually configure that if you want uh
but you know high score is bad low score
is good it's like golf uh and if I click
on this number 21 here and select the
organization uh you should see something
super cool which is our attack path
simul a so let me zoom in on that so you
can see it a little bit better what do
you think about
that very nice there's a lot of boxes
honestly he making me a little dizzy
yeah yeah yeah so the good news is an
actually good old summary there too whoa
another AI doet summary AI summary we
are killing this man anyway look at what
jet is doing here right it picked up a
number of things for us uh we've got a
secure service account key that's
available from the public internet I
like these little red uh exclamation
points here because it actually points
to if we have other um related vul
abilities there's kind of this fractally
integrated set of problems in our
account we can kind of explore that in
any dire it's like Choose Your Own
Adventure it's all mapped out for us
here in this nice little attack path
simulation and it brings us all the way
down to our demo bucket which is where
we have our build log stored so all that
build metadata we were creating before
is actually potentially exposed right
now and this is a good note that we need
to fix it so uh yes that's uh that's
where we're at and so let's think about
for a second what we did here uh you
know I've got my service accounts we've
popped open these uh boxes to get duet
AI summaries of the problem and ideally
we've pointed us toward steps that could
maybe keep our environment safe I I'll
be honest I feel like my mind just
melted a little bit here one of my
longstanding forward wishing look
looking uh just goals for cloud overall
just say hey AI just tell me which of
these containers have vulnerabilities
which policies are over permission and
just give me the steps to remediate them
don't make me guess don't make me put
together a bunch of tools and it really
feels like we're starting to get there I
think we Mark Johnson thank you so
much Security on Google appreciate
[Applause]
you you've got
lore here at Google we like to say that
the best backin migrations are the ones
nobody notices and since 2021 we've been
conducting a massive migration right
under under your nose my name is sudev
bahra and I'm an engineering manager on
the Google workspace team and this
spring my team wrapped up one of the
biggest data migrations in the history
of the
planet we moved every email and Gmail
that's billions of users trillions of
messages and exhibites of data from our
Legacy Storage system to a more modern
system on spanner and I bet you never
noticed the thing
except for maybe faster and better inbox
search but behind the scenes this
migration was a very big deal you see
Gmail doesn't close at 5:00 p.m. or on a
Saturday night the whole migration
process had to be zero downtime and zero
Corruptions every bite of every email
had to be preserved perfectly all while
billions of new messages are flying
through the system every single day so
how do how do we do this we started off
by building an API layer that abstracted
away the reads and wrs from our previous
database and spanner so we didn't need
to maintain two code bases and as part
of this process spanner became sort of
like our system of record so all new
transactions were first written to
spanner replicated and then applied back
to the Legacy Storage system so this
helped us bootstrap the migration and
because spanner was now our source of
Truth the old system became sort of like
a follower
replica I'm not even kidding when I say
a third of the timeline was spent
working with spanner to run Gmail and
spanner more efficiently leading to
Global improvements like spanner more
efficient resi
format so in parallel uh with working
with spanner we spent a few years
building and scaling a migration
pipeline that would rewrite all of our
emails since 2004 all all while we're
still using Gmail so one of the key
technical decisions was allowing the
migration to be a two-way ticket so
accounts could unmigrate if needed we
started off slow you know with our own
accounts dog fooding as we call that and
then scaled up we'd migrate a batch of
accounts find performance
bottlenecks tune the pipeline unmigrate
and then rinse and repeat so remember
this is all happening in production in
real time it's
entirely possible that some of your
Gmail accounts were zipping back and
forth through our migration pipeline
hundreds of times during this period you
never noticed did you we worked really
hard on that so by 2021 we had scaled
this migration pipeline to hundreds of
millions of accounts and we were ready
to start the mass migration and this is
where we ran into the
spanic spicles is a cute name we gave
our edge
cases basically these Barnacles hanging
onto the side of our spanner migration
so here's what it gets really weird
remember email is like an open protocol
right so you can just fire up tnet and
send pretty much any characters you want
over SMTP so some of the emails that
have ended up in Gmail over the years
are unique I'm talking you know subject
lines that are invalid
utf8 extremely large attachment names we
had this message body completely
innocuous and perfectly normal but then
there was this header with thousands of
characters of someone's G commit in it
don't worry you can just put that in the
body we're charging you the
same so some of you have even scheduled
emails to send like hundreds of years in
the future I don't know who you think is
going to be reading these emails but
thanks for almost breaking our migration
system you're very
clever so we knew we couldn't wait until
the end you know to handle these spanic
and edge cases so up front we built
tools to fix them and in parallel with
the migration we went out and fixed all
of these issues that finally thank God
has enabled us to close the chapter on
the migration in May of 2023 and I'm
proud to announce that Gmail is running
fully on spanner thanks to all the hard
work of the
engineers thank you that whole
relational databases don't scale doesn't
really apply to spanner it's proven its
horizontal scalability you're all living
on it oh and we love that blazing fast
sequel we're thrilled to be in a fully
managed service we get to focus on the
business and features of Gmail and
spanner continues to improve and deliver
performance gains all
automatically thank you to spanner and
thank you all for
listening
that was great I'm going to be using
spanic in casual conversation now it's
going to be super awkward uh who wants
that shirt in the in the Google Store
should we add that the spanic shirt
that's great thank you for that so look
we've come a long way in this story as
we've talked about Legacy land and
what's next in Cloud we looked at how AI
can reshape how we think about building
some of the apps we explored brand new
features for making our platforms more
maintainable and secure and now we're
ready to see how the world of data is
changing I'm excited about this one to
help us with that I'd like uh to invite
one of my friends on stage a legendary
Google Cloud Champion innovator miles
[Applause]
Warden good to see you man thanks for
coming thank you yeah uh I mean I was
pretty excited about this I brought an
electric sus phone did you forget yours
or I didn't even know what the ssop
phone was like 4 days ago uh I think the
next Devo is just you shredding on brass
instruments for like 60 minutes I will
rock at least as hard as spanner rocks
for Gmail I mean s's got it yeah I'll
bring my kazoo it'll be good so Miles
you help some of Google Cloud's biggest
customers find new ways to Cloud on a
daily basis I have to believe you're
hearing a lot about AI right now I mean
once or twice right occasionally uh it's
look it's not a buzz workor folks this
is an existential question for all of us
as developers and businesses I I'm
thinking about a project that we've done
together with a customer ours they have
not tens not hundreds but thousands of
internal distinct data sets of totally
unmaintained lineage wow it doesn't
matter you could have hundreds of
analysts nobody can clean that up by
hand and we know that there's valuable
insights in there right that's that's a
treasure Trove but we just don't I mean
how do you get at that so we we figured
there are three big opportunities that
are present first we have to simplify
data operations and that's got to
include security
we've got to put all that data to work
be able to use it using the power of AI
and uh we want our cake and to eat it
too we want our choice of the best open
source tools and manage services so we
don't have to do so much work you ask
for a lot but I will see if we can turn
your dreams into a reality right here
live on the demo stage so if you recall
very back in our very first demo with
Alice we captured some unstructured
audio right we want to get some insight
on it we kind of handwaved away how we
would do that because that's how Forest
works but now miles it is time for us to
get in let's dive in so I did spin up we
jump to the screen a typical data
infrastructure using the analytics
Lakehouse jump start solution remember
these Solutions are available in the
console today they're a great way to get
a head start on Google cloud and figure
out what's possible so these allow me to
spin up in minutes what could have taken
a lot longer to do before I love these
Pages yeah awesome which we'll show now
just for the excitement that's
right so you can gu but just as before
see the architecture we're using big
query we're seeing using big leg data
proc all the things so to start off with
first we actually populate a bunch of
those more audio files in a cloud
storage bucket right a lot of incidents
know what's going on here there a lot of
incidents we created so we're going to
start with these again these are just
audio files right we want to do
something more interesting with them so
to work with them I've gone ahead and
created a new object table in Big
Lake so what this lets me do is it lets
me manipulate unstructured data in SQL
just as if I was working with data in a
traditional schema so here I created
that object table you can see when I run
the query I'll get some stuff back and
what's cool is it's not just listing it
in there it's actually refreshing this
it's constantly pulling in those media
files and now I have a reference to them
in this table just take seconds I'm such
a huge fan of how this big lank model it
simplifies the security operations of
working with data like this what what
Richard's showing is called access
delegation so right now you only need
permission to query the big lake table
in order to work with data that means
you don't need direct access to the
cloud storage you can actually swap that
out with an underlying different storage
layer you could it could be anything it
could be S3 you could be on Azure blob
storage and all the permissions you need
are just the access to data big leg I
hope everybody caught that that's a big
deal when I can be swapping out that
underlying storage layer bring your own
blob as I I never say why am I saying
that here but that's something you would
say so the first thing we want to do
before we can actually transform this
date is get this into a format let's
trans describe it so we can actually
access it more easily so I've got a big
query function here that goes ahead you
can see next speech to text function
this is actually transcribing the data
from the audio file and putting it in
big query it uses the unified speech ml
model to give us some high quality
multilingual
output so we can go ahead we have that
query down here just in case you don't
believe me live live please work right
we don't have trust yet all right there
we go so it's there so let's go ahead
and invoke that so I want to run this
function so it's going to go through
everything in that object table listen
to the audio and then transcribe it for
us I probably need some waiting music
go thank you how you doing I mean
seconds feel like minutes that's
relativity right there we go we didn't
have time for a dad joke there that was
good so if we go ahead and and select
from here what we should
have is a bun of audio transcription so
using this model look we're we got all
of the audio from those files now right
there amazing so you don't need any
complex code no ml there was no ml
hacking done on stage today you don't
even need to leave the data warehouse uh
do you have duet AI enabled in this big
gr project I'm here for you yeah I
absolutely do okay so let's see if you
can get it to find like a specific type
of safety incident like maybe all the
reports that say injury or something
right cuz I'm terrible at writing SQL so
when I can just give it a comment and
have it give me a query statement that's
uh that's making everybody better it'll
also give me some options I might look
and say that's not the one I want or hey
that looks close all right let's pick
that one run that and what it should
give me then I'm querying that I'm
getting only two records back because we
have in injury somewhere in that audio
transcription which is awesome slick
slick slick yeah so notice how we
figured out the table structure I didn't
tell it anything right we went from
unstructured Blobs of audio data to
something that we as quasi SQL devel
velers can actually get real insight on
just a couple of minutes I mean we can
set the bar higher than that Richard we
can get after it we should you know put
on our analyst hat the hell's an analyst
hat is it like a fedora Cowboy or Carmen
San Diego something like that so let's
see if we can transform this data into
something more useful I want to get out
one of the big query studio notebooks
for this
workload yeah buckle up so in this
notebook we can interact with structured
and unstructured data in a single data
frame using big query data frames this
provides a pandas interface so and it
pushes that work to Big query instead of
making us have a big large instance
sitting around with tons of gigs of
memory right so in this example we're
going to use big query data frames but
look I could use spark data frames if
that was a better fit back to your open
source thing it's just about using the
right compute for the right workload I
get and I hope you are too so excited
about this combination of Open Source
and managed tooling like yep give me
spark as the execution engine if that's
what I want alongside big query as a
data repository or if I want to fine
tune in llm and pytorch you know Cloud
tpus now support that I mean I could
bring in data from Apache Iceberg now if
I want to simmer down big man I mean
it's fun it's a lot super pumped I'm
gonna make you even happier though which
is is troublesome I have some data in
Apache Iceberg right here and so what I
want to do I've got this loaded in a
cloud storage bucket and I want to then
go ahead and take the output of our data
also going back into aache Iceberg
format to keep with our Lake principles
here so we have this managed table
terrific we've got some data in from
that table if I pull out this data frame
reference we can actually see the data
that's in here it's a list of
Supervisors terrific let's go ahead and
put that back in there stop breaking
stuff we'll go ahead and run that load
that into the data frame so there we
have our structured data we also have
that unstructured data right all that
audio stuff right and so we've got that
all together which is terrific and then
we'd be able to join this later so I
could join this into information I could
filter it down see which warehouses have
which incidents and so forth and then
even identify the risky supervisors by
figure out which supervisors were in
which ones of these facilities and look
it's Stuart and Kyle time for a little
extra training I always knew Kyle was
going to be a problem sketchy guy so big
L manag tables look we can enable this
and interact with this data just like a
big query table which is awesome and as
you talked about before security is also
managed at the metadata layer so we can
keep row and column data access controls
consistent across the data no matter the
formatter type we have to keep the safe
path the happy path people it is the
only way I think you actually do say
that yeah that's a thing say that so as
you saw we combined all the data here
got it got it processed and now it's
enough information that we can work with
now so good so by joining this we have
new information new insight that's
terrific let's go ahead and then see
that next step how do we do a little
more here sure so if I'm thinking about
how to filter this information maybe we
could use python to send the list to our
training team get them enrolled y do
that as well it's it's not just about
cosmetically improving the developer
experience this is this is time and
money right it's time to First Insight
is always our goal uh you know if
information is hard to find internally
okay everybody at home great hands up
you have all the information you need
it's super easily accessible it's no
problem note there are no hands up in
the audience I mean making information
easily accessible and useful that's like
the Google thing right so maybe we
should make it the easy way yeah yeah so
that's good we've had some fun
manipulating that data but we really
want to get a little more out of this
how do we get some more value maybe we
want to summarize these incidents as
well so we can find out what factories
have which trouble spots things like
that take some action make sure people
stay safe in there so here's where it
gets fun look under the hood big query
studio notebooks are built on top of
collab Enterprise this is the cloud
ready version of Google collab notebooks
that many of you have known in love for
years so when you're ready to take off
your analyst hat and put on your ml
engineer hat what hat is that
uh we can switch over the vertex
AI okay look at this this is the same
notebook so this is the same notebook
we're looking at same data frame same
code all of it but now I'm using collab
Enterprise in one environment
seamless could you call
Palm can you extend that with vertex nii
do summarization from there yeah so
let's let's actually invoke the Palm API
so we can summarize maybe that lengthy
summary there and get back a nice little
description that we can figure out which
factor are a hot
mess oh there we go I think you showed
me the little magic wand button before
look at that I like the wand you know it
doesn't take a lot to please me there we
go and so if we come back we see there's
a summary I'm getting a single sentence
summary of what might be a really long
transcription and I'm doing all this in
the data frame again I'm not leaving my
tool set so everybody take a minute to
appreciate what just happened we pulled
in that vertex integration no containers
or extra side cars we didn't stand up
some giant model or run it on a bespoke
massive instance in order to get it
close to our data it's it's just right
there it's waiting in the platform for
us it's an API call away and you can
make that endpoint available in the app
sheet app from Alice earlier right
that's right Alice is excited we could
just an API endpoint so using AI to put
our data to work is the driving impulse
behind so many of the conversations that
I'm having right now and I I just can't
tell you I can't tell you how excited I
am to continue blowing people's mind
with these features this is what is
going to change buses everywhere I love
it so I'm right there with you let's
have a big hand for Miles W all of our
Champions all right we got some more
coming
[Applause]
up and now the final Legacy
law hi I'm or hle and I work on
infrastructure but uh back in the dark
depths of the last Millennium my my
first real job was to be a programmer on
an IBM 370 Mainframe but then uh pretty
much in the first year uh of this job
IBM brought out their first business PC
the IBM PC it had just
128 kilobytes of memory you know
kilobytes uh slow processor pretty thin
software stack but when I bench Market
it was actually the performance per
dollar was really good and so um you
know 18 months uh 18 years later when I
started as a search engine mechanic at
this little startup called Google um it
was natural to try and build it on top
of PCS because their price performance
was still unbeatable and the software
stack was still pretty bad but there was
this thing called Linux which sort of
almost
worked now physical networking was still
a problem back then it took a while to
get an afford
fixed line between our first two data
centers in Santa Clara and Sunnyvale and
so when it came to copying uh new web
index the new search index from one
place to other to another it was really
hard to beat the bandwidth of a Honda
full of hard drives and I'd like to tell
myself it's going to be okay uh in 2023
we're going to have this awesome Global
backbone where this index copy just
takes a few seconds but you know we have
to start small before we could grow into
uh where we are
today now the other you problem you get
with thousands of PCS with thousands of
discs is that it's kind of hard to keep
track of where your data is and discs
break all the time now two de two
decades ago one of the first things we
did is we built a Distributive file
system to manage these discs and then 13
years ago we replaced it with a more
resilient version uh that's called
Colossus and to this day every single
bite you store it Google Cloud uh in a
vm's disc or in GCS or in a database or
in a uh uh Google drive file is still
stored in
Colossus and now the other problem of
course with these thousands of PCS is
how to manage them and how to place uh
workloads on them in the beginning we
had python config files and and a little
mySQL database to kind of keep track of
them but then about 20 years ago we
built uh the first version of Borg uh
the system that uh to this day schedules
all your workloads in Google cloud and
then uh about a decade ago we released a
open-source version built on the same
ideas uh you may have heard of it you
know what's it called
kubernetes that's right and just to
close the circle main frames are still
around and today you run kubernetes on
them so in fact that's kind of the story
of almost
every software and Hardware uh project
and software and Hardware stack for
sustainable success you need to learn
the lessons from the past and you know
so you can invent the future right and
some call that Legacy I call it building
on the shoulders of
giants and after 20 years in management
actually recently I've returned to my
roots as an engineer and so I'm going to
be working with the Giants on our
technical infrastructure team to
continue shaping the new way to cloud
and all of us at Google are uh really
looking forward to seeing what you will
build next on that cloud thank
you that was awesome so look what's in
the Legacy today we've seen that the way
we prototype our apps the way we
modernize our platform secure our
workloads even the assumptions we have
about our data they not choices that we
have to be trapped in in the past we can
challenge our assumptions even while we
celebrate what came before that's right
and now it's time for all of you to go
build your next Legacy Google Cloud next
will be back in April of 2024 in Las
Vegas Nevada save the date save your
money we hope to see you
[Music]
there